hey guys we're back at Roseanne's
kitchen table my favorite Kelly Carlin
here and I wanted to talk about current
events and sort of how we deal with
carne event yes hi Oh what are you doing
are you doing some kind of video thing
we're we just thought we want some kinda
just you know come in and did Jake tell
me is Jake setting you up right yeah
well your son said we could use the
table here and I know it's going on
right Jake yeah he's over there
come on I don't I have a turkey in the
oven you don't oh good okay good all
right yes person it's a little early for
movie oh I was gonna tell you this is
cherry moon China I was just hanging yes
it's talking up the kitchen here and man
this is some [ __ ] great [ __ ] that's
the good stuff
yeah it is so good looking it's
fermented cherries mush I'll lick it off
the tape holding a little Betty goddamn
rags any place where I'll be up laughs I
know I did it'll have your pot resin on
them we have a whole napkins so this is
what they mean by domestic goddess
napkins well someone we forgot napkins I
know I got a clearly mess man that that
smells like pure oh that's just like
[ __ ] Marty that cough medicine
scissors I'm out with my that is oh yeah
holy [ __ ] that'll clean everything out
if well oh yeah at the bake - okay you
know Obama you know they bust in my my
dispensary wait did you hear about the
thing but got the law today and in the
budget Wow yes in the budget today I
just heard it on the way over that they
snuck in a provision basically saying
they're going to defund all the federal
regulation of medical marijuana
dispensaries and the Republicans passed
this in this in the budget it's going to
happen what does that mean that way I'll
know the fans can't come after us
anymore
America I'll tell you nothing is great
on that subject yeah is they just came
out saying that it's going to be legal
for the reservations you know the Indian
nations real pot which is thank God we
get some industry over there but even
more important than pot I say his hemp
yes that is gonna save all our ass yep
and the Indian reservations you know you
know especially uh Rosebud reservation
hmm gonna start going in the hemp
growing that's fantastic I'm so glad
because I've been like looking for a
long time what is the wait in for
industry and doesn't help it doesn't it
feel like with both of those things that
there's like a little bit more sanity in
the world all right now like like
actually we're not being crazy people
pretending that marijuana is some evil
thing or that hemp is going to destroy
you know something it's like hello
common sense is half that's right it's
very exciting that's very exciting and I
think right now when you look at like
the you know I'm end it a whole other
calendar kind of deal mm-hmm cuz I'm a
Jew and we have our calendar you're on
that thing it's a whole other situation
I'm Angie I'm a real Jew I'm a juju juju
how dare you Kabbalah Jew is that
Kabbalah different than what you're is
there something like a mystical Judaism
which is Kabbalah and then a preacher
assist achill Judaism's in the vaporizer
well you know it's all it's all like you
know there's a higher world than this
one it's right actually right and you
know we're passing through a lot of
gates to get there that's evolution
we're passing through a lot of yep
physical barriers to get to a real I
play some common sense where it what it
really is about is we're going to cease
this division that keeps people blind
and the other one going back and forth
because that's a tactic this is a tactic
to keep us divided so that we
ever nobody ever has to implement
anything that solves even one lousy
problem at place right so we're gonna
let it all go
yes falling yes don't give it no energy
do not do nothing don't participate or
fall yep and keep on moving towards
what's the common-sense solution and
that comes from women yes and women
today I read I was so happy because on
some blog I should have the links but
I'm I'm too dumb
well get him on yes somebody we're
worried about it you know it was a
what's your name Arnold Schwarzenegger's
ex-wife what's driver
Rajaram it's another square something
out the Kennedy the real okay she's got
this study well I'm whatever but she you
know on Twitter um it it says the stuff
I said in my 2012 campaign which I just
offered to the world because I everybody
would be picking it up and I gave it
right you know
and it was fun to think of the [ __ ] but
she said you know we got to start
baltimore mothers interns that was your
whole time now more mentality so friggin
you know and we hear anyway we're coming
to a place where women who are the
problem solvers of the world sometimes
fixing things using with no money using
only a paperclip or a rubber band yep
because it has to be done MacGyver's
inanity right it has to be God take care
of these [ __ ] brats